después de casi dos años de secuestro el
periodista francés Olivia llevó ha sido
finalmente liberado apareció cansado
pero sonriente este lunes en el
aeropuerto de la capital nigerina no
solo decir Que obviamente es enorme para
mí estar aquí estar libre no me lo
esperaban absoluto quería rendir
homenaje a níger y a su saber hacer en
este tipo de misiones delicadas y rendir
homenaje a Francia y a todos los que me
han permitido estar hoy aquí
fue secuestrado en el centro de gao en
el norte de Mali cuando se dirigía a una
entrevista con el dirigente del grupo
yihadista pocos días después se publicó
Este vídeo en las redes sociales en el
que confirmó su detención
soy periodista fui secuestrado en gao el
8 de abril de 2021 por el grupo de apoyo
al islam y a los musulmanes quisiera
pedir a mi familia a mis amigos y a las
autoridades francesas que hagan todo lo
que esté en su poder para que me liberen
el líder del grupo terrorista acmi
afiliado al qaeda había confirmado por
primera vez a principios de marzo con
France 24 que tenía secuestrado al
francés en una entrevista exclusiva el
grupo de apoyo al islam y a los
musulmanes actúa en la zona de las tres
fronteras entre
burkinaher se trata de una región en la
que mantiene una lucha por la influencia
con otro grupo el estado islámico en el
gran Sahara en Francia la familia del
periodista y reportero Sin fronteras se
movilizaba regularmente por su
Liberación Olivia era el último rehen
francés en el mundo tras la liberación
de Sofi pizjuano en octubre de 2020